the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit open courseware at ocw.mit.edu
just very quick
very quick what we're doing today and a
quick what we are doing what we're doing
next on wednesday
philip is going to start with an
estimation lecture
we're going to follow that up with a
lecture from me on sprint backlogs and
task lists
and then we're probably going to take a
break you'll come back and you'll have
essentially a sprint planning meeting
here in class where you will create a
sprint backlog
and a task list hopefully with
estimations down to how many hours you
think all those tasks are going to take
you
then we will ask you to come up and give
a very brief
brief two-minute presentation on hey how
did the process work and what was it
like how to work for your team we're not
actually interested in hearing about
your game
or what the top task you have to do is
we trust that you have a good game in
progress and that you've got a
reasonable set of tasks but we actually
want to hear about how that meeting
worked so we'll also give you about 10
minutes to have a little sort of
postmart review to talk about the
process after you've made your your uh
task lists
um
andrew will then come in he'll be
leading a discussion sort of a review a
review discussion on good software
practices to see what you've been doing
and see if you've remembered anything he
said from earlier
and
you should have turned in your product
backlogs
and you should have code running
on your machines we're not going to walk
around and inspect all your laptops to
find out if you have running code but
but to be on target you really should
have something running and if not
playable at least pokeable
for wednesday
we'll be talking about testing and
you'll be running a focus test in-house
and genevieve
conley yes from riot will be also giving
a guest lecture after the focus test and
i believe she'll be here to wander
around and help out in the focus test a
little bit
so i think that's everything
now i can now those were my two slides
now you can have the controls uh
do try to come in on time for class if
you're unsure about whether you can get
your game set up in time coming early
and make sure that your game is ready
when we have guests coming to our class
we really will prefer it that people
don't don't don't walk in terribly late
just kind of embarrassing
all right
so
over the weekend i was i found myself in
an unenviable position of having to
teach prepare for a video game
class and not having a working computer
so i had to prepare for the possibility
that i wouldn't have a computer as of
today and i and redo my entire
presentation in analog format
but uh turns out that isnt actually does
miracles and got my computer back and
working on monday if you happen to be
working at ismt give yourself a pat on
the back you are doing god's work um
and um but i'm gonna try to do the
analog thing anyway because my white uh
is what the shot i'm gonna do to be very
clear this is the first time that i'm
doing this i'm going to need three
volunteers to come down
come on up
come on
come down yeah
all right
okay
so
on wednesday i we asked you to split
things up into
small medium and large features right
okay
small medium large
and
i'm going to give you
an idea of what
your product backlog currently looks
like your product backlog currently
looks like
a bunch of features
all right
now
i'm
i'm going to
assume that all of you have sort of uh
already assigned small medium large
things to uh to to
uh to your features
sort of small medium large categories to
your features but i want to try it doing
it slightly differently
i'm going to give each of you three
cards okay let's see uh this is these
are the large currents
medium
okay can people see this from the back
by the way the letters
on on the card huh
okay small yep
okay so this is what's going to do
what's going to happen i'm going to pull
something out from here
and you're going to all look at it and
you are going to
to figure out whether that is going to
be small medium large without actually
discussing anything
all right so you keep that the cards uh
uh
hidden but
and only you can see it and then when i
ask you to reveal it
show it all at once okay show me what
you've picked
all right
i'm not going to tell you what small
what's medium or what's large i want you
to tell me what's small medium and large
okay
all right so
everyone clear on how this works
okay
don't don't don't show it to anyone yet
make sure everyone's picked
yes
good question hang on to that
this is a small medium or large feature
with no frame of reference okay all
right so everyone's got one show it to
me
medium medium medium okay all right i'm
going to put this here
next one
can anyone see this
all right
everyone's picked one shall we
medium small small okay why is this a
medium
it's similar
it looks it looks similar all right
okay
okay the other one does have a hole in
it
if you haven't seen it okay i'm going to
put this one aside for now
this one
it is red
all right show it show me it's a small
medium oh sorry still being picked
small small small okay so this is
unequivocally small
and
[Music]
this piece this one this one also has a
color on it
all right shall we come here
large okay
going back to this one
what do you think
everyone show me what what what you're
thinking
everyone thinks that now it's small okay
all right so so don't go back yet but uh
but but i want to say thank you very
much to 12
volunteers why did i just make you all
go through all of that that seems like a
very very inefficient way of sorting out
uh features like if i just gave you this
entire box this is what i want you to do
now sort this whole box into a small
medium lodge all three of you together
you don't need the cards go for it
i think these two are small
tiny cylinder
are these smaller
they're the same size kind of as like
two of these yeah but those are two
tasks right yeah then maybe it is medium
oh that's medium because it's colorful
okay
we'll just make early decisions and
change them later yeah
okay
all right thank you very much
uh
uh
if you can just hang out here just a
little bit longer that would be that
would be great now that is probably a
fairly good analog of how most of you
figured out small medium and large on uh
wednesday which was you just compared
features next to each other figure out
which ones seemed on the larger end
which ones was on on the small end and
just kind of put uh put put things in in
place but there was some discussion
going on
is this small is this large is this like
two
like do it do do two of these put
together make one medium
for
for instance
the thing about uh the first method of
uh of first choosing whether this was
small medium large and then revealing it
was that i forced you to actually voice
out
why you thought that was different you
know i believe you picked the medium and
and the others big picture small
for a lot of these other pieces you
didn't voice anything out
okay and one of the reasons why we can
do this so quickly is because human
beings are actually pretty good at
reasoning about spatial volume you know
yeah
you you're pretty good at uh and and
being you know at mit you also
understand geometry 3d geometry uh
in a sense uh
pretty well so you can make these sort
of spatial
reasonings pretty well but when it comes
to things like time and complexity human
beings tend to have a tougher problem so
i'm going to say for instance i'm going
to give you three blocks
this represents for you
seven hours of work
okay
this represents for you six hours of
work
this represents
eight hours of work
for you all right
so
say you've got 16 you know you've got 16
hours
of work to do
pick out features that you're going to
implement in your next sprint
so this is how much time i have in my
life
uh that is how much time that you spent
on the last feature if all three of you
worked on identical features
yeah this is done this is this is a
known value i believe
okay
you spend some hours on that
you have 16 hours
the first one is just a reference
and a little feature okay all right
all right so so what what did the cube
represent to you again
seven hours of work seven hours of work
and you picked
uh two pieces
and you think that that's a reasonable
amount of work to get done in 16 hours
not including that one not not including
that one so this is about 16 hours of
you know assuming volume equals you know
time
sorry
volume equals
effort actually all right and and and
if you went for more what would you try
to pick one
than perhaps i could do an exactly 16
but it wouldn't hurt to touch it it's
like just one less thing that you can
find right yeah okay all right and for
you this exactly fills my estimate right
realistically i'd probably go for this
okay
okay so so so you're using kind of
programmer uh uh padding yeah
okay you've got a question
balls to your um
but
bringing out the framework itself is a
large task that must be done before you
have your choice of choosing smaller
that's true that's true i i'm i am
i i am not indicating priority in here
i'm i'm assuming that you're picking up
high priority tasks the next thing that
needs to be done thank you very much
and and you may have a seat a big hand
to our volunteers
be going back to this example shortly as
soon as i get my my presentation going
on
okay
so
that sort of
this is i want you to hang on to these
examples because i'm going to come to
come back to to them
during the talk on wednesday and what i
first asked the volunteers down here to
to do was to do a small medium large
extra large
feature sizing basically um the reason
why we we use these broad categories is
because actually it can be pretty fast
and on wednesday a lot of you did it
pretty quickly
however what i noticed on wednesday was
a lot of people weren't actually
discussing
how big or how small these features were
like you were all using your own little
metrics so that was a good
question small medium and large to what
frame of reference right and everybody
had their own frames of reference when i
forced people to make the
assessment you know and then declare it
in front of the entire team and then
discuss if they disagreed with the
entire team then
then assumptions started coming out you
had to vocalize why you thought a
certain feature was bigger or smaller uh
you could adjust your uh your your
your assessment after the discussion but
it's very very important to get that
discussion out to everybody so
as long as you're discussing with your
entire team
i don't really care what method you use
to split things up into small medium and
large
but you need to be discussing as an
entire team in fact
every single member of the team should
be in on the discussion because somebody
in charge of sound design or somebody in
charge of art or in charge of art of of
the code architecture with very
different perspective on any given
feature from other people on the team
and you want all of those perspectives
in at the same time there's oh
um
playing the sound effect that's going to
take no time at all because we already
have sound effects in in our game and
you know we know how that code works
that's what the programmer thinks the
sound designer says wait a minute i need
to create that sound effect i don't even
know what this is going to sound like
yet i don't i have no idea and that's
going to be a larger feature from my
point of view and you want that
discussion to come out
so each role should try to lend its
perspective and it's very important to
listen the reason why i forced everyone
to do this the the volunteers to do this
right at the beginning was because it
was a very sort of turn-based method of
of getting that discussion out i had to
force everybody to listen to everybody
and something that i didn't ask our
volunteers to do was
offer alternate uh
solutions however they kind of did that
automatically by themselves when they
were when i just left them to their own
devices they said sort these down into
features
they started discussing well this is how
i look at the problem this is how you
look at a problem and uh and they
quickly came to some sort of consensus
of course something i mentioned on
wednesday was if you've got a really
really huge feature that's kind of hard
to figure out you know it doesn't really
fit neatly into any of these boxes break
it up into smaller features
you want to converge you want to
converge down into a
a consensus
but there are right ways and the wrong
ways to go about that
you um every time you have that
discussion you're getting new
information into the team about how
complex a certain problem is maybe
sometimes through that discussion you
discover a certain problem it's easier
or a certain feature is easier to
implement than you had originally
expected so and then you redraw seeing
other people's estimates is actually new
information and that's actually what
happened here it was small small
medium and um and the people on the
the volunteer team uh figured out what
other how other people were seeing the
problem
here's something that's very important
don't negotiate don't say you know um i
think it's small you think it's small
most of the team thinks it's small
somebody thinks it's medium
just change your estimate down to a
small you know that you know if the
person is kind of adamant no i think
this is a bigger problem than you think
it is
don't try to negotiate with that person
because you think because that person
has a valid point of view and this
starts to focus the discussion on
changing the person's mind not focusing
on the future you actually want to
figure out how complex this
a certain feature is for the same reason
don't take an average someone thinks
it's a small feature someone thinks it's
a large feature that doesn't make it a
medium feature that means that your team
has no idea what this feature is because
you aren't in agreement with how complex
something is
so
what i did does anyone remember what i
did when uh
let me see which which feature was the
weird one that people were kind of uh
hung up on i think it was this one when
i was
when when we got to this one and there
was some disagreement can anyone
remember what i did
it's up there yeah i just put it aside
right i actually put it i actually gave
it away
um
it's very very easy to get into a long
drawn-out discussion about how large or
how small a future is it's usually much
more clearer if you sort of tackle the
easy ones first and then get come back
to the ones that you disagreed on but
you remember that you disagreed and you
got new information in the process of
talking it out
so that's a that's the role for the
scrum master the scrub master says we
don't want this feature estimation
process to take too long so we're just
going to put that feature aside first
look at the other features do the
estimation on that and then we and then
review it later but the scrum master
does not decide what size that feature
is the whole team has to come to a
consensus you want to converge on a
single estimate
so
that's a so if you've if you put
together your product backlog
and you never really discussed with the
rest of your team
what those size estimates were then
that's something that you're going to do
later today before the end of today i
want you to have a discussion about
whether these things are actually small
medium or large
and the reason
is
because estimation it is not just a
process of just putting down numbers or
letters on a spreadsheet there is a goal
for the process of estimation and it's
this is to get a clear enough view of
the reality of your project so that you
can make informed decisions to control
your project
in order to hit the targets
now you know what's a target target is
you know a goal that you wish would
happen it's yours your fondest desires
is to is to get this project done you
know uh entire product backlog of all of
the features uh into your game before
the deadline that's that's a target
right maybe your target's a little bit
you know closer term what can you get
done by this week what can you get done
by this sprint it's still a target it's
something that that you want to hit but
you can't
base your decisions based uh uh you
can't base all of your decisions on your
fondest desires
you have to base it on on what your
team's actually capable of doing
and estimation is a process of actually
trying to understand what your team is
capable of doing not whether you know uh
not
not not not what what you want to happen
but what can happen
so
what are you estimating
you're starting this is where you are at
right right now you have a product
backlog and you have size you have
feature size
that that is going to get broken down
into
a bunch of tasks each feature is going
to be broken down into individual things
that individual people can do you know
maybe a certain feature like jump
involves art involves code involves
sound involves debugging it involves
integration all of these are individual
tasks that might be carried out by
different people
so what you're really doing
in the second step is to figure out how
much time something is going to take
remember what uh drew said on on the on
the very first day of class
it's not so much how hard something is
how hard the future is but how long it's
going to take and what you want to do is
figure out how long it's going to take
now there's a process of arriving at
that number of like how many hours is
this really going to take and is it
going to fit within the amount of time
that we've actually uh uh
given the team
and there and you need to translate it
first from size into effort which is you
know like total amount of effort that is
going to be used to tackle the problem
split it up among the people who are
actually going to work on it and then
each person has an individual amount of
uh
of efficiency so for instance i gave
exactly well uh i gave exactly the same
cue to all three volunteers but i told
them this meant different things to each
one of you
and when they picked off
tasks of the product backlog they they
picked they picked it based on their own
personal metric that's what you've got
to do too
when you decide that you're going to
take on a task you have to assess it
based on your own ability to actually
execute on a test say it's an ai problem
and you're not
you know very well birthed in ai it's
going to take you longer than somebody
who
has done ei that has done artificial
intelligence
before but that's okay because maybe the
person who is doing artificial
intelligence is
busy trying to solve a hairier problem
establishing the base framework of of
code and that needs to be done first and
that needs to be done sooner so that
person is busy you can start working on
on certain
uh features even though you may not be
the best person to to do it that's fine
as long as you make an honest assessment
of how long it's going to take you to do
it
size estimates like i know are pretty
easy you can just you're just sorting
things into buckets very large buckets
time estimates are very much like
hitting a moving target
as you
start to make estimates you are going to
discover that many of those estimates
are just flat out wrong
you're going to say oh that's going to
take me four hours to do and it takes
you four days to do
and you're gonna have to communicate
that to your team
estimation is
giving an estimate is not the same thing
as making a plan
it's part of the same process
but i want to be very clear about what's
the difference between estimation and
planning
say somebody on your team asks you for
an estimate
you know
does anyone's alarm bell start going off
when it says how long is this going to
take you to do
anyone's kind of starts to get worried
because you're not quite sure whether
they're actually trying to ask you for
how difficult is something and how much
time do you think it's really going to
take or
are they asking you can you get it done
by monday
you know that that that that's kind of
like the hidden the the hidden question
that they're not asking about but but
but but they think that they're asking
so you need to be very clear whether
when you respond whether you're giving
an estimate or a plan
you plan to reach your targets
obviously none of you are i hope none of
you are planning to not hit your targets
okay i plan to get this done one week
after the deadline oh
okay
but once you've made your plan you know
here's our entire product backlog and we
think it looks reasonable and we think
that it can actually be done by the
deadline
you need to make it you need to start
making estimates to see whether that
plan is realistic
you can say yeah i think that's a
reasonable estimate a a reasonable
estimate when you think that that that
assessment is accurate yeah i've done
something similar before so i figured
that this is something that we can get
done before the end of the week you know
you can you can commit to that estimate
but you haven't committed to the plan
you haven't said i'm going to take
responsibility for getting it done by
the end of the week that's a very
different thing
when you accept the task and say all
right put my name on that spreadsheet
and i'm going to make sure i know
i have decided that i think that i'm
going to be able to get this done in
four hours so i'm now committing to this
plan
of course then everything goes wrong and
you re-estimate you're allowed to make
re-estimations while you work on tasks
you have to because
no plan survives first contact with
actual development
so here's a quick quiz
here are four statements that you might
hear
in the middle of a team meeting
okay
i want you to tell me what each uh what
each one of these things are i have i've
already used these words the words
describing each ones of these things in
in my talk
so far
it has to be done in two days what is
that
it's a deadline i i use another word to
describe that it is a deadline
uh is it a plan
is it it's a target
someone
all right
so
the next one it'll take about two days
to do it you know yeah you're talking in
a team you say this feature looks like
it will take about two days to do it
that's a
that's an estimate that's right
i'll need two days to do it
that is a plan that is a plan that you
are committing to more accurately it's
like it's like i'll i will take two days
to do it you might take
three days to do it you might be able to
do it faster than the
dummy and do it in one but i'll need two
days to do it and of course the last one
is
actual reality it actually took two days
to do it right i mean in reality like it
took four days to do it um
so
i want you to be very very clear that
when you're communicating with your team
what you are trying to say you know i
are you giving estimations on you know
given all the information that you know
this is how tough something is going to
take and this is how long is it it is
going to to take to get this feature
working are you making a personal
commitment saying this is my
responsibility now i'm going to get it
to you by monday
um
just a
quick side note you've probably seen
these two words come up in numerous
engineering classes the difference
between accuracy and precision which
one's more accurate
uh uh fault uh
raise your hand in a direction that you
think is more accurate
okay that's all actually
okay i think there's a majority on this
side all right which one
which means that one is more precise
okay
so
that's that's right this is more
accurate there's closer to the target
that you were trying to hit even though
it's kind of like broadly you know
spaced out you know none of them
actually hit the target but if you took
the average of all them you know you get
pretty uh uh you you you get pretty
close to the center that one's a really
nice tight grouping anyone here do
pistol or archery or rifle yeah okay all
right so so so you know we always talk
about how how how how tight the grouping
is when when when you're shooting that's
very precise that can be corrected by
say fixing your the sights on on on on
on your um
on a pistol or on a rifle but
for time
estimates this is like consistent
underestimating right it's like yeah
it's going to take me two days to do it
i'll get it done in two hours really it
took four days and four hours right and
you're always doing this
um when it comes to estimation accuracy
is more important than
precision because you're going to work
on multiple tasks
and if your estimates you know they're a
little bit off all the time but
sometimes you're under sometimes you're
over that kind of averages out which
means that you can still
you can still make some effective plans
but
if you are constantly consistently
underestimating or consistently
overestimating you need to figure that
out quickly you need to learn that about
yourself during this class so that you
can start to you can start to correct
that and if you can't figure it out
hopefully somebody else in your team can
realize that your estimates are always
offered a certain direction and then
adjust the plan accordingly
it's also important to know what the
uncertainty of your estimates are
it's very it's available to know how
imprecise an estimate is you know it's
like this week this could be done in a
week if i find someone else who's
implemented a feature just like the one
that we want if not i'm going to have to
implement it from scratch and it's going
to take an hour
it's going to take uh um
four weeks to to to implement i mean
that's a fairly common scenario
so it's very valuable to know how
imprecise an estimate this
but
while i while i welcome that kind of
discussion in a team
don't just give a range don't just say
well that's going to take anywhere
between one week and four weeks
that's too wide a range you can't
establish a plan
on that you know how many of you been in
this situation right you know two
minutes remaining and it just kind of
like sits there and it's really like
four minutes later it's like what the
heck is going on
um
it'd be much better if you had actually
that progress bar
and that progress bar is actually giving
you a single point estimate right this
progress bar is kind of telling you this
this job's about 15 complete you know
and it's telling me it's two
two minutes remaining
um
and and that bar still has a long way to
fill up
so you realize this estimate may not be
terribly accurate because not working on
on a lot of information it may be an
optimistic it may be a
underrate it may be a pessimistic uh
estimate but you still need to commit to
a single point estimate if you want to
make a plan around it don't just use the
average of a range the difference
between
one week of
a one-week estimate and a four-week
estimate for the same feature is not
somewhere in between you know it's it's
not like oh it's going to take
two and a half weeks the one-week
estimate and the four-week estimate are
two very different circumstances one
week if you found somebody else's code
that basically does the same thing four
weeks if you had to write it from
scratch
one week in you know exactly what
situation you're in right either the
code is done or the code is not done and
you know it's going to take four weeks
your estimate is still it's not like two
and a half weeks that's that's you're
not halfway in
between
the good news is that time estimates are
entirely internal to your team no one
outside your team needs to know this i
don't need to know this sarah doesn't
need to notice none of the graders need
to know what your time estimates were
we're not holding you to you know with
uh to
your grade is not dependent
on this
this means that you can revise your
estimates over time and i'm going to
encourage you to do that
you are not neo you aren't going to be
faster just because you want to be
faster so it's important to actually
understand what's your actual pace of
work
now
this is something that i'm going to
recommend that everybody do starting
from today and that's to track your
estimates this is one way that you can
do it um it's not the only way but you
know it's good enough where you write
down the feature that you were working
on say it's the jump feature and you
have the tasks that you took on you know
i'm going you know i'm i i'm a coder so
i'm going to say
i'm going to put some upward velocity
when the player hits the spacebar
i'm also going to write some code to
play a sound effect when that happens
these are two separate tasks and they
were the original estimations you know
that was going to take eight hours
that's going to take five hours and then
you actually write down how many hours
you've spent on this task so far
you know the first you know for the
first task it was done it took me 10
hours to do all right longer than i
expected so
my you know so my eventual estimate was
10 because i actually i actually knew it
took 10 10 hours to do if i ever have to
do that same
same feature again you know the same or
feature of the same size again a task of
the same size again to be accurate uh
then i'm going to estimate all right
next time if i think it's going to be 8
i'm going to write down 10 instead
because you know it's it because that's
what previous history has told me
but say i'm in the middle of writing my
jump uh sound code
i thought it would take five hours i've
spent two hours on it
and i look at it and i think actually
this is a lot this is a little easier
than i thought it was going to be so i'm
going to like say all right probably
only another two more hours of work on
this and my current estimate is actually
being revised downwards
so this is going to get faster and if i
put this in a public location where you
know my scrum master can read this they
can actually see
my progress on my work
you might be able to also do this on
certain task tracking tools
don't estimate in ideal work hours don't
say like if i had four uninterrupted
hours to just work on this game i am
going to you know get this this jump
thing uh working how many of you ever
have four uninterrupted hours
really is this like between midnight and
four yeah okay all right
okay yeah you know um
really okay uninterrupted you're not
like checking facebook or
having to get a snack in between no
really
amazing okay
if there are distractions if there are
team meetings if there are uh you know
other problem sets that you that you
expect to have to do uh you should count
it you should count it in your task time
uh you should you should be able to
account for for for for this because
it's like say say you've blocked off 12
hours off of
no let's say six hours you're going to
spend six hours on this project over the
week
um
and you know you've got that because
you're going to spend the rest of your
time going to other classes and doing
other work
and you know that you've got a one-hour
meeting somewhere in there right
part of your task is actually going to
that meeting and figuring out you know
how a certain feature should be
implemented before you actually start
writing the code or actually start doing
the art for
for it you want to factor that into your
task estimation you don't want to say
that's a separate thing you know or at
least if you do count it as a separate
thing make sure that you've actually got
that as a separate task with the actual
time estimate on it count all of your
distractions do try to schedule and time
box all of your meetings because it
makes estimation easier if you know that
the meetings time box to one hour you
can't you can't spend more than one hour
in a meeting and you can actually
account for that in your estimations
don't just always have ad hoc meetings
for instance like on skype because then
they're just like stealing little bits
of you know a couple of minutes from
everybody's schedule all the time
without anyone being able to plan for it
so if you've got something like this
where you're tracking uh all of your
progress then you just add up all of
your time estimates when the feature is
done
and then you can go back to your
original small medium and large
and say
you know this thing took me seven hours
seven hours to complete
and if i get another feature that looks
like you know
these two features for instance
and say you know yeah it's about you
know two half features compared to that
seven hours so i said okay three and a
half three and a half
and you can use that it's not going to
be perfect it's not going to be accurate
but it's you're basing it on real
evidence of how fast you personally work
so you so all of this information helps
you become a better estimator of your
own performance
and in the future you can use those
numbers for future sprint planning so
you know you finish one sprint uh say
it's project four and you've got
multiple sprints you finish one sprint
and you know that this takes you eight
hours to complete so the next time you
get
this size feature it gives us well it
took me eight hours last time so you
know i'm going to say that that feature
looks like an eight uh eight hour task
you should
re-estimate every day so you animate
your jump
and say that's too big of a feature so
i'm going to split it into two tasks
the animate the jump takeoff and the
animate the jump landing
since they're two very similar tasks i'm
going to put the same time estimate on
both of them and then i'm going to start
working on jump takeoff since you have
to go in the air before it can come down
and i'm going to start working on this
it took me
a little the task is a little bit harder
than i expected so originally it's a
five hour estimate so i'm going to
increase that up to a six hour uh
estimate
and then eventually i got it done down
to zero all right i have no more hours
on this feature it works it's tested
it's integrated everything's fine
now i have to do the second feature
animate the jump
landing
what should i write down for that
let's say by the time i actually came to
the situation where i wrote down i had
six hours remaining i had already spent
eight hours working on the future
okay i wrote i spent eight hours working
on jump takeoff and it wasn't done then
i wrote down i had six hours left
so what's my new feature estimate
14.
a lot bigger
um you know because that's how that's
that's real evidence now of course it
may be that during the process of doing
this earlier feature you've learned
certain techniques that's going to speed
up your next thing however that's
wishful thinking that's that that's hope
that's that that's what you desire will
happen in reality the the actual
information that you have is that
actually if you add up all the hours i
actually spent on this it took me 14
hours so i'm going to revise the next
feature and let the rest of my team know
that i think this next feature is going
to take 14 hours
divide and conquer if you've got a very
big feature very very big big task
breaking them into little bits and do
your estimations
don't don't forget
to add in uh to account for debugging
uh this is one of the very first actual
bugs found by admiral grace hopper it's
stuck in a vial somewhere in a computer
in 1940 that actually caused the program
to fail
um that's what that's one theory of
where the term debugging came from um
don't forget integration time taking
your code and your assets and you know
uh your writing and your dialogue and
sound effects and
making them work with other people's
code and contributions
don't forget that
some of you are going to get very
exhausted and overloaded
while you're working on this project
don't forget to take breaks and to
account for those breaks in your time
estimation if you know that you don't
tend to work well on a four hour stretch
and you tend to work much better with
one hours with you know a five minute or
ten minute break and then another hour
uh then use that in your time estimates
try to estimate so that you uh so so so
so that you can work efficiently not
just you know
how how you wish you could be working
any
questions i ran a little long on that
yeah i know that was kind of fire hosey
um
that's it we'll we'll probably get back
to this
actually we will actually have you
practice this later on uh in in class
five minute break all right so uh right
now we'll do a five minute break while
we switch our computers around be back
here by
153.
okay
we are we are back on
so we're back on
um hopefully this will actually not be
terribly long because at least some of
the stuff i'm talking about philip has
already
really touched on and discussed in more
detail than i need to hit since he just
talked about it
i'm just taking a lot of the terms he
has introduced and explained and talked
about all the estimations and tasks and
so forth and stuffing them back into our
scrum framework so you can think about
giving that data about estimating what
do you do with it how do you how do you
show it how you share it with it how do
you record it
um so but first
let's have a really quick review
remember i said there would be a quiz
later here's our quiz
um
i want to see if how many of you
actually still remember what we talked
about on monday so can i get some
volunteers to give me some definitions
up here
just one one per
in charge of maintaining the customer so
that the team has gotten on track yep
specifically prioritizing the backlog
but yeah okay
someone else
she's getting a really long
uh lecture daily scrum is the daily
short meeting where every team member
talks about
what they've done what they will be
doing and what's calling them great
next
grab them while they're easy
the product backlog is a list of
features to be implemented
okay and i saw someone
okay
right somebody else somebody else
got two meetings left grabs meetings
team members
don't make me do the whole lecture over
again because i don't want to give it
and i don't think you want to hear it
the retrospective is a meeting at the
end where you review your processes
yep
[Laughter]
team member is really easy
nobody's grabbed that
team members everyone that's on your
team
excellent well done
do i have anyone who'll take scrum
master
you've already answered twice thank you
for for noble
go participation and everyone knows what
they need to do without actually doesn't
actually need to do anything
he's not actually in charge of
planning anything he's just in charge of
making sure everything goes smoothly
yeah yeah
coach is a great description for that
okay
all right now i think we have not hit
the sprint review meeting but other than
that i think we're pretty good
um
so the sprint review meeting is the
meeting that you're going to get to do
in class today
no it's not sprint planning meeting ah
sprint planning meeting is the one
you're going to get to do in class today
where you go ahead look at your product
backlog decide what you can get done and
make a sprint backlog and then break
that down into a sprint task list
and
i don't think anybody gave sprint review
okay and sprint review is just at the
end of your spirit when you saw when
you're evaluating your project for how
close it came to what you had intended
to make
and it is a chance to change and update
the product backlog by the team usually
led by the product owner
um since they're the person with the
vision and a lot of strong opinions to
modify any changes to the plan that you
guys have realized now that you see what
you're what you've actually made um i'll
stop torturing you now
so backlogs task lists and tasks
first step is
creating a sprint backlog
it's pretty basic it's pretty simple
usually your product backlog ends up
having lots of really big stories big
fancy features the things you want your
your game to do when everything is in
and it's all working at the end
by nature these are usually big stories
we want to have physics so that the game
feels realistic
i want the player to be able to develop
lots of different powers through the
game i want to be a long complicated
story i want there to be lots and lots
of characters to interact with i want a
fully immersive world
never ever put that in a backlog but i
want a fully immersive world these are
all you know somewhere past extra large
often
but in a product backlog it's okay to go
that big but when you're actually
thinking about what you're going to do
this particular sprint and this
particular iteration you've got to get a
lot smaller than that for example i want
a fully immersive world is not getting
done in one sprint even if it's the only
thing you're working on so clearly
you're going to have to break that down
into smaller stories and the place you
do that is usually your sprint planning
meetings
so as you break those really big stories
into smaller stories you can leave some
of them on the product backlog because
oh my gosh we're not touching those yet
and then you can decide which of those
pieces of the story
are complete enough and small enough
that you can get them done in the sprint
be it one week or two week or a month
and again the size of stories you're
grabbing is really going to vary based
on how long your sprint is by definition
the sprint you guys have income have
have coming up is one week because your
project's due next monday
so
um
once you've got your stories broken down
you've pulled out and you've got your
sprint backlog
then you can start taking a look at the
tasks but that's not quite how it works
because it's kind of easy to grab too
many stories onto your sprint backlog at
your first pass and when you actually
start going through and estimating
things and you realize just how much
work each of those stories take you may
find you have to put some of those
stories back
you may even realize that some of the
stories that were at the bottom of your
priority list are actually more
important than you thought because
you've got other stories higher up that
depend on them
so
while you're doing your planning and
while you're making your sprint backlog
and making your task list all sort of
all a little bit you know you're going
to go forward two steps back a step
forward three steps as you both reorder
your backlogs
put stories back take stories back off
as you realize as you're trying to
figure out how you get all those
dependencies
and
squished into what is actually a really
short amount of time so you guys don't
even have what a sprint team thinks of
as a full week you do not have a 40-hour
workweek ahead of you
you have per person probably a 10 to 12
hour work week because that's about the
amount of time the class expects you to
put into it
so
small small stories small tasks
okay i just went through all of that
didn't i
um how do you break things down
um when you're breaking down your
stories think about
what's the most important part
of what you're breaking down into
and as your stories because your stories
have a because or so i can
you can start thinking about what is the
most important part of that story and
which of those stories which portions of
the stories you can just dump maybe you
don't you don't need a full physics
engine to create realistic driving
because what the heck does realistic
driving mean in this case anyway does it
mean that it accelerates and it really
feels like it's accelerating properly
does it mean that when you take handle
curves you can kind of feel it spinning
out on you
and what does feel mean anyway does it
mean that the computer is playing really
realistic sound effects for me that i'm
getting really cool sparks
off of the wheels i'm getting this view
of the car spinning out
when you understand what you actually
want then you can create smaller stories
that let you break it down
and sign up just for that you can also
take a look at what the abilities of
your team are
and what you can actually do if you have
somebody who's really good at sound
effects maybe you really want to try to
create a realistic
oral environment you're not going to
worry so much about the physics you're
not going to worry so much about the
sound effects but boy is it going to
sound sharp that's okay that's working
within your capabilities and your
limitations to do your best to fulfill
your overall vision
um philip really already covered this
pretty well
i will i will zip right through it
um
tasks think of them in terms of going
down to a half hour is probably a waste
of your time if you if you're if you're
looking at a whole bunch of tasks that
are half hour long that's that's a
really small amount of time um on the
other hand eight hours is probably the
biggest you want to look at given that
that's most of a week ideally you don't
have one task that takes up your entire
week's worth of work if so you're
rolling some really big dice there
because you're assuming that your
estimate is pretty good and especially
the first time you start estimating your
estimate probably isn't that good it is
it is more common for people to
overestimate by up to twice as much so i
can get this task done in eight hours
often means i can get this task done in
16 hours
think about that as you are tasking
things out and as you are creating your
sprint task lists
um
let's see
yep okay so i think we've mostly covered
that
um
finally
once you have this big pile of tasks on
an excel spreadsheet that no one
actually ever wants to look at again
because they're kind of hard to pick out
there what do you do with them
i mentioned scrum boards and i mentioned
them being preferably they're a physical
scrum board that's really not realistic
for us so you're going to want and i
really strongly do recommend that you
use a visual scrum board solution
two that i have used on projects that
work well for different situations are
trello and scrummy.com don't feel like
you have to use either of these if you
find something better use it and tell me
about it because i want to know
especially if it's free
so let me show you very quickly
let's see if i can pull them up
so here is
that's showing okay here's squirmy.com
which i actually i think it's kind of
the easiest and quickest one to use
it is
like this is always going to be more
work for your scrum master so when
you're thinking about tasks
set some time aside for your scrum
master who's probably going to create
this board
it's going to be your responsibility to
maintain it move things over but
somebody's going to have to type tasks
into it
and
it would work best if everyone could be
relied upon to type in their tasks but
it rarely works that way especially
since you often have a whole bundle of
tasks that haven't been assigned at
least at the beginning of the sprint
because people start picking them up as
they discover that they've gotten stuff
done
so
pretty much
it works much like a scrum board.2 so
you can create
you can create all your tasks it divides
things up naturally by stories although
if you'd like to put it by user you can
there are two standard ways to organize
a scrum board either organizing all your
tasks by
by the story it belongs to or by the
user who's working on feel free to do it
however works well for you
scrummy because it's free and you don't
want to pay for the upgraded version
won't let you change the names of your
columns but it's pretty hard from the
end of the world
um
so
if my story is to demonstrate show me
the crafts i have recorded the url so i
can get back here that's done i've made
a new board that's all done and i
confirmed the board was there
um i've assigned a task to philip so
there can be a task there
and it's really pretty quick and easy ah
no don't delete it
it's really pretty quick and easy to go
ahead and edit things
it changes color so you can have
different colors easy to tell apart
and it's really just sort of a click and
grab
click and drag except that i don't have
a mouse sorry i don't have a track
counter and so it takes the fancy
two-fingered
maneuver to actually move it so i'm
gonna fail to move it over but they're
they're pretty easy to just click and
drag to the various things to the
various sides
so that's scrummy which has less
functionality than trello but it's
actually in exchange for that it's quick
and easy you type in a task you type in
a name you're done
um trello
i apologize about the resolution here um
let's see if i can close this
yeah
um
trello
lets you go ahead and create as many
columns as you'd like
you can name them whatever you want
um
they have
you can you can put in all the
information you want if you want to
track your estimations here if you want
to have a checklist of subtasks that are
related to it if you want to put on
pretty little labels
so that every user has a different color
or every story has a different color as
long as you only have five stories
um
um but on the other hand you can also
waste a lot of time organizing your
project on trello and it will look
really nice and we'll have all the data
there and you will have sucked all those
hours that you could have been coding or
drawing or actually making a game
so trello can be really nice to use
but don't let it steal your project from
you if you choose to use it
i was told that there is a cool scrummy
there's a cool scrum free download
extension runs in the chrome browser
that makes it work better for scrum
because it adjusts lists and it does
some previous setup for you i haven't
tested that so i don't know how it works
if you'd like to try it out do but don't
do it this project because you don't
have time to waste mixing it around and
fixing it up do that on on outside time
if you really want to is is my advice to
you
i don't want you to spend a whole lot of
time getting the perfect system together
i want you to get a system that works
well enough and use it
okay
yay back to the slideshow
so that is scrum
boards don't use powerpoint either
apparently it has to be difficult
um
so the classic the classic lineup on a
scrum board is you've got all the tasks
in your to do pile
you've got the in progress and anything
in progress should be assigned to
someone should have a name attached to
it it can't be in progress if someone
isn't working on it and it should have a
time estimate attached to it
ideally the time remaining
although if you've got you know it's
good to keep track of how much time has
actually gone by on it that's the task
the task cards are really good places to
keep track of your estimates as they
change
right then it's all in together in one
place
um
you'll definitely want to have a once
you get finished it should not go over
to done it's going to testing someone
who is not the person who did it should
test it and then move it over to done
that way you've got a second set of eyes
on every piece of code and every feature
just confirming it's working
many scrum boards also have another
column called blocked or on fire which
is to say this is a task that someone
can't get done until someone else gets
something out of my way
it's nice to have
it's not required
and if you're working on a board that it
isn't you're having a hard time fitting
everything into one screen um
excuse me one screen
trello has always a problem for that
with me it's okay to leave it off but it
can be really helpful to have so that
that sort of is a scrum board and i do
really recommend them they are useful
i know it feels like a lot of extra time
often when you're setting them up
but if your team is actually looking in
there and checking it every day and
updating it's a really good way for the
team to spend to know where it's at
without having to spend a lot of time
talking about it because all the all the
really basic stuff
is there to be seen which means you
could freeze you up to talk about any
real problems that are coming up
okay so that said it's your turn
um you've got a week left to work a week
left on your project so let's try
creating um a sprint backlog
and a task list from that backlog
for what you're gonna do what you're
going to get done for monday when you
have your turn in
i'm going to give you like all meetings
this should be time boxed so i was going
to give you half an hour to do it
i will check in at half an hour and if
people are screaming oh no we're nowhere
near done i will give you another 10
minutes or 15 minutes not actually a
whole lot more time but i'll give you a
little more time
this is probably doable in half an hour
if you guys have been working on your
project and you've got your product
backlogs in good shape but it's the
first time you're doing it so it's all
always it's hard to know what the right
amount of time is
after that i will give you five or ten
minutes probably call it five minutes to
talk about the process
and have someone come up and give a very
short presentation of what the process
was like
what worked what didn't
whether you liked it or not it's okay to
come up here and say
i don't feel like this helped us at all
just come up and tell us what happened
and how your team how it worked for your
team that's
nice
nice
[Music]
we use scrummy to try to organize our
product backlog into our sprint task
list
we found scrummy to be a little annoying
because it doesn't automatically update
instantly you have to refresh the page
and as long as whatever happens last we
find is what the it shows us what's
edited so it shouldn't
break but it's not the most useful thing
i think more useful would be to use
google
use the google doc of the product
backlog
section out the stuff that you do in
that sprint and then just update it
there we have it all like color coded so
it looks really nice and that's much
easier to look at and
do that i think
like importing that into some other
program and then like doing everything
there and then going back it just seems
better to use google okay
thank you
fantastic
[Applause]
okay so we used trello for our scrum
planning and we like trello because you
can just like create cards that have
like lists of tasks and easily move them
around between different columns like so
when someone takes on a task they can
move it to in progress and like assign
their name to it and it's really easy to
look at and
see what's going on at a glance um
trello does have a lot of features like
checklists um that you might not want to
use a lot of especially if you have like
really complex tasks you don't want to
put all of those inside the checklist
because that gets confusing um the thing
that we had the most problems with was
doing time estimates for the tasks
because we have not like no one in our
group has used phaser before and so we
have a very kind of like shaky grasp on
how long things are going to take so our
guesses are mostly random
at this point in time but we will uh
update that as we get more experienced
uh one thing that we did find was really
helpful was when we were drawing up
goals we did we broke down all the
features that the game needed into like
as like fine grain detail as we could
because um we know what results we need
to have to get the game to work but we
don't know phasor yet so we don't know
exactly what the processors are gonna um
entail yet but having like uh the list
of things that need to go into the game
gives us some guidance on what we should
be
developing towards
thank you
[Applause]
sparkly redemption
[Applause]
okay sparkly redemption we basically
just opened up google docs and made a
whole bunch of excel spreadsheets
i think we're kind of trying to use
scrumdu and see how that works but we
figured it'd be best to just kind of
finish the thing first and then take a
look at that so no thoughts there yet
um i guess we basically just took a look
at what we wanted to get done by
wednesday and what we wanted to get done
by the end of the week and then broke
that down into the
tests and then worked with that um i
guess estimation was
it wasn't too bad because some of us
have worked with phaser before but there
was also a lot of things where we
realized oh well assuming x is finished
first then y will be really
straightforward but do we count x's time
inside of y well maybe but maybe not
really
so that was as complicated as it got i
think
[Applause]
so for us we started out with a fairly
uh
detailed plan and we used asana which is
multiplayer to-do list so similar to
scrum
but
ultimately our entire team more or less
got sick over the weekend and we didn't
actually get much work done so we can't
speak to exactly how good our estimates
would have been or how useful our plans
would be so
all the planning in the world doesn't
help if your entire team is in bed
[Applause]
so our team used primarily google docs
what we did was we had our product
backlog and we were a little confused
about the product backlog so we made it
way too detailed but that really helped
with this so we ended up copying and
pasting our product backlog into our
sprint task list deleting everything
we'd already finished and then
adding based on what we had done and we
found that because we were further along
in our project it was really easy to
tell what needed more work and to get
the tasks more detailed and better
estimates just because we've done a lot
of it already
[Applause]
um
so we started out planning on using
trello but did the product backlog in
google docs and since it's sort of the
same information repeated twice we sort
of just stopped using trello and ended
up using google docs anyway and that
sort of helped us out now because all we
did was sort the things in google docs
by priority so we looked at the things
that were highest priorities so we're
doing this week and then we just sort of
thought about each one you know how can
we break this down what are the specific
tasks you started working on this what's
left to do here and then we put that
into the
sprint past list yeah
[Applause]
uh so we've been using google docs from
the beginning uh we decided to not use
any other site because we had already
started working on google docs and um
it's worked out pretty well for us we
were able to
take our product backlog and take the
highest priority tasks that haven't been
completed yet and just split them up
into a finer detail task that we can use
for the
sprint task list and um
i think that that worked fine for us so
it helped us really scope out how much
time we had uh how much time we helped
us reevaluate how much time we needed to
complete the tasks that we had to
complete and
i think that that
is going to help us for planning for the
rest of the week
thank you
all right so i have in fact as we say
iterate on everything i've iterated on
this presentation and been changing the
order of it so it maybe i get confused a
couple of times i hope not we'll see
um this is we're gonna talk a little bit
about
um high level and low level
here but as we said in this class we
want to iterate on absolutely every
process you might use this is how you
control your team this is how your game
works everything and this is actually
not a bad philosophy to do to everything
in your life that you might want to
consider trying stuff fixing what
doesn't work embracing what does work
and moving on but this also applies to
how you write your code
and i can talk about this on a high
level and a low level the the where you
put your parentheses and exactly what
kinds of variables you use is a process
and you make decisions on that basis
every
every moment that you're coding and it's
a really good idea to think about what
you did and how well it worked for you
or someone else
and this is the kind of thing that maybe
as you're in your early programming
career you don't want to think about too
much because just getting the stupid
thing to work in the first place is kind
of hard but i'm going to try to convince
you that it's worth your time to get
these habits going so it's easier for
you in the future to debug your code or
someone else's code
so i'll talk a little bit very briefly
about something i mentioned in the
review on the lecture on game engines
which is that all software sucks
and it sucks in different ways and all
that right
well the problem with this is
as it yours does too
your software is going to have bugs in
it and your job is to try to make that
as
happen as little as possible you want
your software to suck as little as
possible
now we also talked about a little about
one of the things one reason we use a
game engine is just that you write less
code overall you spend less time doing
that that's because everything that you
do when you're writing code is slow
and in particular
debugging is the slow part
it's not too hard to write new code but
it's actually pretty hard to go into old
code and fix what happens it varies
depending on the complexity of your task
but generally speaking when you've
written a bug
you later you have to spend the time to
figure out that there was a bug figure
out where it was and then you actually
have to fix the stupid thing and that is
actually where most of your time is
going to go when you're trying to
develop code
and we talked so again figure out the
problem and then change the code to fix
your bugs but i claim that most of the
time figuring out the problem is more of
your time now this isn't true for the
small bugs when you're typing something
your computer and it doesn't work when
you compile it or whatever and it runs
you go back and fix it right away yeah
that part of debugging is not so much
figuring out the problem because you
just wrote it it's fresh in your mind
you know what's going on there but if
it's been a couple of days or a couple
of weeks then it's really actually the
hard part and the slow part is figuring
out what went wrong
and so
one of the things that you need to think
about when you're writing your code is
you want to make it as simple as
possible so that you're less likely to
write a bug in the first place or once
you have written a bug
it is it sticks out it's easier to see
and the important thing to remember here
is that all this code you have written
is not as easy to read as you think it
is
and the right way to do this
is to make it as easy as possible and
the way i like to think about it at
least today
is to make it require as little
knowledge as possible to figure out
what's going on in your code
if you use some really fancy language
features that's really cool and it feels
like you're really smart when you're
doing it but a week later you go back
look at that code to try to figure out i
don't even know what i did there and
heaven help you if someone else tries to
read your code
so ideally you don't want to go too
obscure into the computer language fancy
features you don't want to go too much
into your subject matter
there are acceptance to this if for
example you work on a very specialized
piece of software where everyone has to
have
an
aero engineering astro degree to
actually work on the project you can
assume some level of competency there
but generally speaking in game
development and other most application
development you want to assume as little
knowledge as possible so that when you
want to debug your code you can look at
the little part of the code you're at
right now and see if you can figure out
what's going on there
if possible you want to
assume no knowledge in the part of who
was reading your code
and i'm going to talk about why that is
this is a useful thing to think about
for user interfaces or really any
problem solving humans can't hold that
much in their brains at once
and if you're trying to write code that
requires you to think about 10 different
things at once
you're in trouble because humans really
don't do that
now generally we get around this problem
what's called chunking so if you're when
you started with math right you thought
about
the number five wasn't even a numeral to
you it was five objects
but you couldn't really wrap your brain
around 12 because you can't look at 12
objects and think oh i understand what
that means but as soon as you practice
with your numbers more you begin to
think of the number 12 say as a unit
it's not 12 things it's one thing it's
the concept of 12 and that's really
useful to you and then you started
working through algebra and you've got
variables and now you're using calculus
and all these other cool things you talk
about vectors in math a vector
represents three numbers or a direction
or position in space but you don't think
about all three numbers and you
certainly don't think that 35 is one of
those numbers and that means that there
are 35 things your brain isn't wasting
time on that instead your brain is
thinking it's a vector it's a point in
space that's all i need to know
so your brain's ignoring a lot of
information but sort of clumping a bunch
of information into one spot
i often use phone numbers as an example
for this and it's an increasingly poor
thing to use because i bet most of you
don't memorize phone numbers because why
would you
but when they started mending phone
numbers there are three parts to a phone
number first part's an area code the
second part is sort of a sub-area code
and the fourth part is the fourth part
the third part is the four digits that
are more unique right
um
it's really hard to remember those ten
numbers but actually once you learn the
area code the area of course three
numbers you think of it as one
number boston is mostly 617.
the second set of numbers is also three
numbers you clump that as well and the
last four numbers you have to memorize
those but basically instead of
remembering ten things you have to
remember
six things the four numbers and then the
two prefixes
and another problem with coding is that
as you keep doing it you're making
decisions constantly in your coding
what's the right way to do this what's
the right variable you're going to use
etc etc and as you do this you get tired
humans only have so much decision making
in them before they need a break
so a couple of things we can do is we
want to reduce the amount of things you
have to remember while you're looking at
your code and we want to reduce the
number of decisions you're going to have
to make
and to some extent although i'm not
really clear on the psychological basis
for this i'm going to make the crazy
claim that figuring something out and
deciding what this thing must mean
is a decision so even if you're just
trying to figure out something that also
is a burden on your brain and what you
want to do is keep your brain alert and
hopping as much as you can for as long
as possible and to do that again you
want to simplify your code if you can
so
sort of to go back here
simplicity when i say simplicity i mean
you want fewer things to think about
it should be easy to read the code so
you don't have to memorize what the code
is doing you can just quickly glance and
get a reminder of what it's doing
you
have fewer bugs because there's fewer
moving parts fewer things to go wrong
i'm going to say this hopefully a couple
of times but
a short variable name is not simpler
it's just shorter
if you start thinking about what you
spend time doing when you're writing
code and trying to get something done
what takes the most
time i'm willing to bet it's probably
going to be debugging part but maybe you
think it's going to be getting a stupid
thing to compile in the first place or
whatever but i'm willing to bet that
almost none of you think that your
typing speed is the thing slowing down
your coding
if only i could type 80 characters a
minute i could double my coding speed
it doesn't work that way
you do a lot of thinking and just a
little bit of typing so if your variable
name is 12 characters long instead of
four characters long that is not costing
you time
it's just costing you eight keystrokes
and in a modern development environment
you've got auto complete you type the
first four characters you hit control
space and you get all 12 hey you can't
even claim that you've saved eight
characters you've only saved six
so anyway
i'm going to talk about that a lot
because i believe that sort of the
longer variable names are really useful
cues to remind you what you're doing
and one of my favorite expression things
to talk about is white write wants read
never code
who here has used pearl anyone
have you tried to read other people's
pearl code
yes why would you try
have you tried reading your own pearl
code
no that's
that's right you just try it again
absolutely so pearl if you're not
familiar with is this cool scripting
language it kind of it's it's not used
as much now but it was once the open
source darling
um php is kind of modern equivalent of
my god why you right don't try to read
that code
but um
pearl had the nice feature where pretty
much every symbol on your keyboard has a
meaning
and if you want to do something there's
probably three different ways to do it
with three different obscure characters
on your keyboard
worse each those characters has a
different meaning depending on what
you're using it on
but this is an example of apl code
which is
a stands for a programming language
developed in the like late 60s early 70s
and it's really
painful because in apl not only does
every character on the keyboard have a
meaning they minted special keyboards
with an extra three characters per key
so that you could have more characters
and this is awesome if you think of
writing code as a piece of paper with
your pencil and you're doing math you're
writing fancy integral symbols and this
and that sure
it's handy in math to chunk those
concepts this way but for coding
generally speaking we're stuck on our
alphanumeric keyboard with a couple of
symbols and i advise you to use as few
of those symbols as possible try to
stick with your language if you can
alright
who here thinks that you write enough
comments in your code
wow some of you do but almost none of
you so is it maybe a core of you were
like
i'm proud of my comments
it's cool be proud of your comments if
you're writing them and if you're not
writing them don't be so proud of them
but sometimes i see comments that are
just duplicating what the code is saying
if your if statement says if x is less
than 5 don't put a comment up there that
says if x is less than 5 do something
that's a waste of time i can see that in
your code but i want to know why you
care if x is less than 5. that's the
kind of comment that i would like to see
in your code
and i'll get to this a little bit later
but i also talk about longer variable
names longer function names those are
useful ways to dodge writing comments if
they are correct
um but really quite frankly if you're
trying to figure out gosh i don't know
if i should comment this or not
write one it's not going to hurt you
so i'm going to here's an example
these comments don't mimic the code
but what they do do is they tell the
story of what the code is actually doing
um random aside font is actually very
important with your with your editor
make sure you use a fixed width font
because pretty much all programmers do
and if you want sometimes you're going
to use spacing to have everything lined
up nicely and you want to have that be
crystal clear to anyone else using your
code
but
there's no way to do this so this is
code you can figure it out go ahead and
figure out what you think it's doing
there's no rocket science going on here
we're using the pythagorean theorem to
calculate a distance and make sure that
if it's small we return 50. there's
nothing hard here a programmer can
figure this out
but a programmer shouldn't have to
figure this out and that's my argument
if it takes you i don't know maybe
you're great and it takes you two
seconds to figure that out maybe it
takes you 30 seconds to figure that out
it doesn't really matter it should take
you less than that if the code has been
written correctly
so
for example i'm splitting up the 900 to
30 times 30 because why the compiler
doesn't care
it's a little bit easier to read you can
say if the distance is less than 30 as
opposed to if the distance squared is
less than 900
this does have a bug good catch
there's a bug here this code doesn't
work
because we're saying y 0 minus 1 instead
of y 0 minus y 1.
so there's a better way of doing that
this is even easier to read
we are using a vector instead the vector
class has some internal knowledge of
what means to subtract vectors and what
the length of the vector is not only is
this less bug prone but this is actual
it's
just easier to read
and that bug you just that you caught
there can't happen
now this code's a little bit cheating
because i used v for the name so you can
kind of guess that they're vectors but
that's fine
here's comments basically the same code
i'm saying hey
here's some context
this is a lot more code
in some ways it's harder to read
in some ways it's easier to read
that's one of the things you have to
figure out for yourselves you know what
coding styles make sense for you
obviously simpler is a subjective
question
but i kind of like this style of code
because what it does is it means that
even if you don't comment your code your
code still has commented because you can
read this and know what's going on
more importantly and this is what i've
changed since the last year i gave this
presentation
i thought that the comments saying why
and then the code that did it was
probably the better way to go but a
friend of mine pretty quickly convinced
me that actually
f codes get maintained for a year so you
might change the code and forget to
change the comment this actually happens
a lot in real software projects
with the kind of commenting or the kind
of self-documenting code that i'm using
here
that can't happen if you change the code
you change the comment it's innate
they're instrictly linked because they
are the same thing if you can do this it
actually helps a lot
all right
um so i'm going to go through a variety
of tips and tricks and things that might
make things a little bit easier to read
but before i do that i want to talk to
you a little bit about
sort of
um why and who it is you are helping
so a while back i was complaining to my
grandmother that wow you know last year
i made a bunch of stupid decisions
i didn't do this right i didn't do that
right i'm so much smarter now this year
than i was last year it's amazing
and my grandmother said yeah i feel that
way too all the time
she was 84
and i thought oh no when i'm 83 i'm
still gonna be a [ __ ]
so one of the people that you are
writing code for one of the people that
will be reading your code is not other
people on your team although they're
very important but it's you you will
read your code later
have any of you been looked back at code
you wrote six months ago
yet you're early in your career so not
many of you have but i'm willing to bet
when you look back at the code you wrote
six months ago you think to yourselves a
couple of things one wow i was an idiot
and two you're gonna think to yourself i
could write this better now
and three you're probably also thinking
even if the code works the algorithm is
solid this is decent
it could be more readable maybe you
aren't thinking that yet i want you to
start thinking that
because you're going to forget the code
that you write and again when you're
just starting out that seems impossible
that you're not you can't forget code
that you just wrote but i guarantee you
after you've been writing code for five
years or more
a lot you're going to discover you don't
remember what you wrote yesterday or
last hour
as well as now when you're just learning
and getting deep into it you remember a
lot more than you're going to
but keep in mind that experience you go
back to your code and you don't remember
what you wrote that's the experience
your teammates have every time they look
at your code they didn't write it they
cannot remember it
your code is a communication opportunity
to talk to your team to let them know
what it is that your code does
all right so one way to make a bit more
readable shorter functions um you hear
this sometimes
all of us eventually write that 500 line
procedure that does this then that then
the next thing to the next thing we all
do it because it's the easy way to do it
you think i'm going to do this thing so
i do step one step two and you march on
through
it's reasonable
it's a way to get things done especially
when your work is in progress but if you
ever want to go back and fix that code
now you have to figure out what pretty
much all 500 lines are doing and that's
kind of dangerous
the easiest thing i can recommend there
is if it really is a step one step two
step three kind of thing why not divide
steps into sub functions the sub
function may get called once but that's
okay
the reason this helps you is twofold one
it gives you a nice name for this
section of the code is where i am going
to
tell all the planets to to build
spaceships this turn
i make that a function call i don't have
to worry about
what's inside that function if i'm
trying to debug a war mechanic
because probably the part where all
plants are building spaceships isn't
relevant to
the gigantic space battle off somewhere
else
but two when you sub function this
inside that sub function you are
guaranteed that the local variables
there are unimportant for everything in
the big function the scope is such that
they can't affect the big function their
local variables you don't have to worry
about that so this is a tie a couple
little class of of bugs that you can
kind of dodge by something as simple as
subdividing a function
two and this is the other important
thing you've got this function you strip
it down so hopefully you can see it on a
page in your editor
and you can read in english kind of what
it's doing you see here the five steps
there they are
it's a little bit easier and that's kind
of a simple straightforward example but
it's that way of thinking again that i
want you to think about
if you ask five programmers what's the
right thing to do they're all going to
give you different answers and that's
fine but the thing i want you to start
doing is thinking about what is it that
you think is the right thing to do
why would you consider doing it this way
versus that way if you just write the
code and don't think about it you're not
going to get better as quickly as you
will if you think about why you wrote
the code that way and how it's working
for you
here's another fine example
making wrong code look wrong this is
perfectly valid code
unless i make my variable names a little
bit more descriptive
and then you discover that that's wrong
code that code is terrible
um degrees times radians is a classic
mistake centimeters and inches has
destroyed mars rovers
milliseconds
kilometers
and
miles per hour that's probably not going
to work so well
and these are actually
you say i never do that but again i kid
you not we have lost billions of dollars
to unit conversions because people
didn't do this
it's going to be annoying to you when
you're typing it in perhaps but i
guarantee you you'll be safer if you do
it
um again random stuff you've probably
heard all this and when you're doing
games you get a chance to really
experience it firsthand try to avoid
sticking numbers deep in your code no
magic numbers you want to stick it in a
variable somewhere this has a couple
good features
one of the biggest is you've got someone
else on your team can easily look up
that number and change it they don't
have to find it in your code they can
just look at this your list of variables
somewhere and figure it out
in unity it's even more awesome because
you can just go to the editor and
change it around
also you can change it globally
everywhere if the number 50 is magical
great but call it something else so you
can change it to 51 when you're tweaking
your gameplay
i've talked about this before and i will
talk about it again if i get half a
chance you want longer variable names
that say exactly what they are you don't
want to have to guess
they should be pronounceable and this
isn't true for everyone but most people
will tend to in their mind say a
variable name out loud
and so if it's a bunch of random
consonants that don't go anywhere it's a
little bit harder to read
if they look similar you don't want to
have the typo kill your project
spell them correctly and this is
actually really important especially an
interpreted language it doesn't just
doesn't do
any thing except running at runtime in
python for example i believe if you
declare a variable that's never been
seen before it probably has a valid
value
no okay good i'm glad that's true
javascript that's what i'm thinking
but javascript be very careful
especially if you're using phasor
javascript if you mistyped the name it's
zero
that's no good more and more modern
languages are rejecting that um but the
other thing is just it's easier for your
teammates to know how to spell it if you
all agree on a spelling and if you're
all gonna agree on spelling you might as
agree on the correct one
and then reusing your variable name is
also a little bit dangerous sometimes
if you're exiting a loop and you've
maybe failed to initialize something
properly you reuse a variable name
elsewhere
you've got this weird value coming in
and that's that's a bug waiting to
happen that'll be kind of hard to find
function names all the same rules
basically apply you want to have it be
distinctive spell correctly do they want
to say what they do it's tempting
sometimes to make a function name really
really short again that doesn't speed
you up and the function name is longer
you get a chance to read what it
actually does
but the other thing about function names
and this is even more true for other
parts of coding is that your function
name tells your other programmers what
the heck you just did
i wrote this function well what does it
do well read the function name it's
right there that's ideal you can't
always pull that off and when you
function does something more complicated
than you can describe in you know four
maybe five words
then you need a lot of comments to
describe what that function is doing
ideally your function should be slimmer
than that if you can manage it
um
by the way i mentioned variable names
and lengths and you probably a lot of
you're probably thinking right now yeah
a long variable name sounds a good idea
in principle i don't want to type that
it would slow me down to read it there's
actually been research done on this
topic
8 to 20 letters on average is often a
marker for good code that works with
your bugs so i'm not talking a little
bit longer if you can push it push it
harder and to be along as you can stand
and then you'll be a little bit happy
with that
if you were coding in you know
vi or punch cards still you could
complain about a 20 variable
20 letter variable name but you aren't
you're using a modern development
environment with autocomplete i hope
variable scope and names
ideally and this is the thing we strive
to do and don't always succeed at you
should name your variables so that you
can tell by looking at them where they
come from by which i mean is it a global
variable is it a local variable is an
argument to the function
that kind of thing you can sometimes do
this by prefixing or post fixing or
camel casing or not camel casing that
kind of thing it doesn't matter which
system you use as long as you're mostly
consistent
um
trying to be consistent among different
programmers is often difficult because
everyone will horribly disagree as to
what the correct answer is
but if you can try to sort of remove
that from your brains and say actually
it doesn't matter what it is this time i
just need to know what you're doing
that's the important bit
um parallel rays these are three arrays
and item number three in each array is
related
um this is something you're going to
find yourself very tempted to do a lot
especially in a game
and i recommend it against it even if
you only have two parallel arrays i
recommend making a container class that
contains both pieces of data and have
them stick in one array
just because you're going to get bits
sometime by having these rays get out of
sync you just want to avoid that if you
possibly can
order of operations there's an
expression up there which is probably
legal code in most languages
and we're taught in algebra that we
should memorize the order of operations
so we know what what gets multiplied
when and all this but in computer
language we've got a lot more we've got
incrementation we've got raised to the
power of we've got modulo we've got all
this crazy stuff
and my argument is don't
why waste brain space on memorizing the
order operations for like the eight
different kinds of operations you have
when you just use parentheses and remove
all doubt
plus you could also even divide that i
would divide that up into a bunch of
different statements actually um there's
no reason to keep it like that there's
no way everyone looks at that expression
and thinks this is the most intuitive
way to understand this
if you're writing on paper in in math
class you might find that because you
can use two dimensions you actually can
make your your equation more more
intuitive but in code you most only have
the one dimension and so it's kind of
hard to really make your math intuitive
so i would put extra effort into just no
split it up
um i also mentioned this last time i'm
going to mention it again it's very
important warnings should always be
treated as errors
i don't
i can repeat it again but basically
every new warning is a hint something
might be wrong
and if you let your build be cluttered
with warnings you will not notice when
the important warning pops up and you
could you can lose hours to that just
because the build wasn't at zero
warnings
backwards conditionals
which of these looks wrong
the second one looks wrong
i agree the second one totally looks
wrong and yet it's useful because what
happens if you mistype the equals equals
sign
if you missed out the equal equal sign
that second one doesn't compile
it depends on your language of course
but generally speaking it's it's a handy
little trick that i find useful and
everyone else i know thinks is terrible
so you know don't necessarily use it but
try to find tricks like this that caused
to be the case that when you mistype
your code you get a compile error
instead of a bug in your code
warning
it will be a warning absolutely which is
an even better reason to not to screw
down to zero warnings right
it doesn't help if it's a warning that
you just let go by
and it should be warning i'm glad they
added that when i started programming it
wasn't a warning wasn't that wonderful
um i mentioned splitting up the math
um i think that that first thing is you
know you can read it you can figure it
out
i think that the second thing might be a
little bit more comprehensible
again it depends on who you are
this is one that i'm emphatic about i
mentioned order operations before
bar minus minus that's fancy in some
languages i assume most the model ones
these days bar minus minus means do the
math and then subtract one then
decrement bar by one
if i had said minus minus bar i'd have
meant decrement bar by one then do the
math
and this is pretty cool it's this nice
little language trick but
if you don't happen to know what that
means you've just confused your fellow
programmer with your language trick
that second thing is perfectly clear you
know exactly what happens do the math
then decrement the the variable
and if you really want to get pedantic i
guess you could say bar equals bar minus
one but
draw the line somewhere
um i'm a fan of booleans being sort of
asking a question
like the boolean
purple probably means is purple
um the boolean hungry probably would
mean that are you hungry
but the boolean desk might not mean
anything but anyway try to to to make
your bully into a question that has an
unambiguous yes no answer which way is
true which way is false
status is a particularly bad one
because
i don't know what that means is status
true good is status true meaning that
something bad happened i don't know
without some help
you've probably heard this before
mysterious constants don't do it
ideally if you can define it in your
language you get an error when you do
when you mistype it and that's much
better mysterious string constants is
particularly the worst you're going to
be very tempted to do it in javascript
but you should probably have a define of
some kind at the top so you don't get
that problem
this is a language construct
which is very handy but i recommend
using it sparingly
if you
are asking a question if you want to set
a variable to a value it's often very
convenient to do this syntax but really
you don't want to ever nest these if you
nest them it becomes unreadable
gobbledygook and if your expressions
become complicated it also becomes
unreal gobbledygook
again i'm not saying you can't figure it
out because i'm confident that you can
but why do you want your future you to
have to spend 30 seconds to a minute
figure out what the heck you were saying
instead of two seconds figuring out what
you were saying
go to
we are told the go-to is evil all the
time always i claim it's not always evil
but you should be careful when you use
it
it's particularly useful when you're
exiting a horrible set of nested if
statements but the main reason go to is
evil
is because of a thing called proximity
which is that you should use things
near each other in the code if i declare
a variable and it's two pages screen
pages up from when i use it that's kind
of a difficult thing to figure out
that's one reason to keep your functions
short
but instead if i can clump it together
i'm less likely to make little simple
little errors right here i'm doing the
same thing to x and y
and i'm interleaving it because i'm
thinking of it as i want to prepare them
i want to calculate i want to print it
but it's a little bit easier i would say
to to debug and think about it if you
treat each one separately
and if you get a lot of these well write
a loop or something there's no reason to
to actually print it to type it all out
all i'm saying is keep it keep it simple
as simple as you possibly can so that
later when you get back to it you can
figure it out quickly
um you're going to be very tempted to
make complicated systems in your
prototype games
even though your game spec is changing
probably daily
so you might want to be a little bit
cautious about that rather than making a
complicated system solve the problem you
have today
and then maybe two days from now when
you know for sure you're actually doing
that you might put more effort into it
this is advice that's not good for all
projects but it is good for very short
projects it's tempting to create a
complicated system that will do
everything you need is attempting to
create one solution that will solve all
of your woes but you might very well be
borrowing trouble and solving a problem
that you're never going to have
so given that you're probably talking
about fast iteration your game is
changing all the time
don't
and this is counter to my architectural
design thoughts but don't design too
much
because you're going to change it all
anyway
other things that cause bugs are
recursion recursion is awesome recursion
is fun recursion is really hard to debug
try debugging someone else's recursion
and you'll be very sad try debugging two
things that call each other even sadder
and it looks really cool but i recommend
don't do it
similarly optimizing
wait
you think you know what's slow and
what's fast
chances are
you don't
um if your development system has a nice
profiler we'll tell you it'll tell you
exactly where the bottlenecks are
exactly why your code is slow wait for
that and fix the actual problems don't
waste time chasing ghosts
particularly this happens a lot when
you're trying to do
some code and you're thinking oh this is
really important it ends up being called
once per second well once per second
computer time is never
so don't bother optimizing that but the
nice thing here is that a profiler can
tell you what you need to actually fix
i've mentioned fixed street warnings as
errors before i'll mention it again
probably
but similarly you want to fix a bug as
soon as you find it if it's in your head
right don't think oh that bug is easy to
fix i'll get to it before the end of the
sprint
because you might not remember it four
days from now as clearly as you do right
now
also if you've just written the code
it's much much easier for you to
actually fix it
because it's all much more fresh in your
mind
strongly consider not fixing bugs that
don't matter
and this is a tough one
because i just contradicted myself with
saying fix them right away and now i'm
telling you sometimes don't fix them but
basically if fixing the bug is going to
cost a lot of time and it's not going to
improve your game enough
then consider leaving it
that's going to be a thing you have to
talk about with other people on your
team but you know hey
so for example if you've got every j in
your text renders green for some reason
and to fix that you need to go to the
font library and do some crazy code well
don't
claim it's a feature
days are green
obviously if you're doing microsoft
office you can't do that but we aren't
we're doing games
so we can cheat like that
use a debugger if you do not yet know
how to use a debugger take advantage of
this class to learn how to use a
debugger
i can't really say more about that do it
when you're also trying to figure out a
bug talk to a teammate even if your team
has no clue about your part of the code
the act of putting into thoughts and
words this is what my system is doing
will a good third of the time cause you
to realize where the bug is
it's kind of silly but it totally works
so if someone comes to you on your team
and says hey i need help and you're like
cool i'll listen to your problem and
they talk to you for 15 minutes and then
say i got it and walk away
don't feel useless
you just save them an hour
and it cost you 15 minutes and that's a
bargain
right and don't feel embarrassed about
it if you if you're the person talking
to the per talking and talking about
your bug it's great they may ask you
questions that are irrelevant you're
like no no
that's okay too you have to explain it
that orders it in your head and then you
can solve the problem
and then of course take a walk
i have solved more bugs going to get my
lunch or in the shower in the morning or
whatever than i have at my desk i would
say at least more tough ones
binary search is a thing it's kind of
hard to describe
but
rather than necessarily saying this
could be the problem i'll test that this
could be the problem i'll test it if you
can do a test that says well
roughly half of the potential problems
that could cause this bug are over here
and half of them over here and i can do
one test that won't tell me where the
bug is but will eliminate this entire
tree
that's a good test to do
you can quickly narrow in on where your
bug actually is
and this happens a lot too with beginner
programmers if your bug goes away
it probably hasn't gone away
it's just hiding now
so be sure you know why the bug went
away if it's the green jays you might
not need to worry about it but
even then you might want to think about
it because you thought you knew what the
green jays were and they went away and
you didn't fix it
who knows what's going on here it's
worth putting so a little bit of time in
to make sure there isn't some serious
bug hiding under the covers
i'm not going to source control again
we've already done a little bit of that
um
you
you need to do source control
if at all possible everyone on the team
should be able to just get it get the
code and do a build that should be as
hard as it is
and on that realm
daily builds are awesome if you can
afford to have someone on your team
whose job it is once a day i don't know
midnight pick a time
do a get a fresh get do a build make
sure everything works
this sort of forces all the programmers
on the team to sort of be more careful
about making sure their code works and
also if something gets checked in that
breaks everything horribly you know
about it right away not three days later
there are automated tools that will do
this for you at least they'll check the
compilation step that might not check
that make sure everything's still
working but you know it gets there a lot
um coding standards why do we use them
and
we like tidy code and obviously the
braces go in one place or another those
are terrible reasons to have coding
standards
um instead these are the reasons that i
like a little bit more which is
my code don't touch my code well you're
on the same team i'm going to touch your
code if if i need to and it's midnight
and you're asleep and i need to fix the
bug that's the way it is but you
shouldn't be mad about that we're trying
to fix the game the fact that i that you
wrote the first pass in the code doesn't
really matter
um
and then of course decision fatigue the
thing i mentioned earlier we talked
about what variable names to use and
what algorithm to use or this or that
we've got plenty of decisions to make
where you put your curly braces should
not be something you waste time
stressing about
um
you know if you have a coding standard
use that if you don't have a coding
standard be consistent if you're
modifying someone else's code stick with
their coding standard because if nothing
else when you do the check in it will
look like the entire file has changed
just because you changed the indentation
strategy and that's not very useful if i
want to know what changes you made i'd
much rather have a minimal set of
changes that i can look through and see
what the actual meaningful changes that
you made were
and of course
easy to read easier debug hey
a lot of things i've been talking about
are things you can read a lot more about
there are people that have written
serious books on the topic of making
your code as easy to read as possible
steve mcconnell in particular has he's
at this point his his books are are
older but they're still perfectly valid
because the science of writing code has
not really changed much joel spalsky
also has a much easier to read set of
blog posts that talk about this kind of
thing it's much more accessible and it's
free
and he's the person who his company is
behind trello
which kind of indicates
that his method of thinking kind of
matches with our method of thinking
there's a lot more things to think about
in these realms there are
in terms of ways to make your code
easier but again i want to go back to
the core concept we talked about before
you're going to have a couple projects
during the semester where you're going
to see a bunch of different coding
styles yours and other people's yours
might even change over the course of the
semester and that's good
but you should include perhaps as part
of your post-mortem process
what kinds of things did you like in the
code you saw what can you pull into your
coding style that is going to make your
code easier to read or easier to debug
and maybe you can try to influence other
people to write prettier code you're not
always going to agree what pretty code
is
try to let that go when it happens the
important thing is you should think
about what you're seeing so that after
your project is over you are a better
programmer for it
and i think at this point
um unless you have any questions we'll
go on to heaven's project time with the
remainder in 15 minutes
rick i printed it there